PROFESSOR: OK.
So what is our
Schrodinger equation?
Therefore, our
Schrodinger equation
is ih bar d psi dt is
equal to 1 over 2 m.
H bar over i grad--
that's p-- minus q over c a
squared plus q phi on psi.
We're going to motivate
that next time.
But let's look at it for
a little while, at least.
There's several things
we've done here.
We've replaced p by
p minus q over c a.
So this is a replacement.
P has been replaced by that.
We used to have p
squared over 2m.
Now we have this quantity.
Well, we'll see why that
is the right thing to do,
but you could ask
yourself, is this p still
intuitively equal to mv or not?
And the answer is no.
That's not really mv.
We will see that from
Heisenberg's equation
of motion, but intuitively,
when you have here--
this is the energy
of a particle--
kinetic energy and
potential energy--
the kinetic energy--
1 over 2m times m
squared v squared.
That's p squared.
So 1 over 2m m squared v
squared is 1/2 mv squared.
That's the kinetic energy.
And that should come from here.
So what we will
see is that, if you
want to speak about
the velocity operator,
this whole thing is
the velocity operator.
We don't speak, really, of
velocity operators in quantum
mechanics before we put
electromagnetic fields,
but here, it will be natural to
call this m times the velocity
operator in the sense of
Heisenberg equations of motion.
This operator is Heisenberg
equation of motion--
is going to look like the
Lorenz force equation.
So it will be reasonable
to think of this like that.
This operator is nicer than
the operator p, as we will see,
for many reasons.
So we've emphasized gauging
variance so that, perhaps,
the most important
thing we could say, now,
to end up this
lecture is, what is
the statement of gauge
invariance for this Schrodinger
equation?
So gauge invariance
means that the physics
that you obtain with
one set of potentials
should be the same
as the physics you
obtain with a gauge-equivalent
set of potentials.
So I will say this way--
suppose you solve the
Schrodinger equation
with h bar over i
grad minus q over c,
with the new potentials--
plus q-- or you solve
the Schrodinger equation
with the old potentials?
So you have here
the two Schrodinger
equations-- one with
the new potentials, one
with the old potentials.
They should be the
same physical solution.
This is not going to be too
obvious how to do, however.
How do I guarantee they are
the same physical solution?
I'll have to go on a
limb and try something.
Look.
Here are the gauge
transformation.
That's what a prime is.
That's what phi prime is.
Should the same psi
be a solution of both?
Should this equation
imply this equation,
so that the same psi works
when you change the gauge
potentials?
That would not work.
That is asking too much.
Certainly, the same psi worked
would be simple looking,
but that's not what you
really have to demand.
It's not going to be
able to occur here.
What you're going to need
is to change psi as well.
The gauge transformation
is going to affect the wave
function, too.
Not only the electromagnetic
fields get gauge transform--
the wave function must
be gauge transform.
And you would say, OK.
That sounds a little dangerous
because if you change the wave
function, you're going
to change the physics.
Could happen.
But the change in
the wave function
is going to be subtle enough--
is going to be just by a phase.
That can still
change the physics.
If you have a complex phase,
you can change the physics.
But will be simple
enough that we
will check that the
physics is not changed.
So the claim of gauge
invariance is a statement
that this equation implies
this, or this implies that,
if psi prime also transforms.
And the formula
is-- at psi prime--
should be equal to e to the
i q over hc lambda times psi.
So that's the key to it.
When you transform
the potentials--
when you change a to a
prime and phi to phi prime--
you should change
psi to psi prime.
What?
With what?
Using the same lambda
that you needed
to change the potentials,
you do a phase rotation.
And it's not a constant phase.
This depends on x and t.
So it's a substantial change.
So you now have the technical
problem of first checking
that this is true.
This is the statement of gauge
invariance of the Schrodinger
equation.
There is a way to
transform the wave function
so that the new
Schrodinger equation
solution is obtained from
the old Schrodinger equation
solution.
And then we will have to check
that the physics is the same.
If you wanted to
compute the expectation
value of x, on
this wave function,
this phase factor would cancel.
So it would give you the same.
If you want to compute some
other expectation values,
it's a little funny.
So there will be operators that
are nice for wave functions
or [INAUDIBLE] gauge
invariant operators.
And it will be a nice story
that we will develop next time.